personality types who makes more money
do you think usually pessimists are
optimists
does the pessimist start with money
do either start with money or that's a
good question because because i had a
meeting with the founder of with the son
of moody you know the moody's family
ever heard of moody's moody's moodies
they're all over the place in texas
and i had a meeting with the guy and i
went and pitched him an opportunity 11
years ago i said here's what i think we
can we can make billions
and i was done with my presentation he
says patrick there's two types of people
in the world
there are those that wake up every
morning
wanting to make their first billion and
there are those that wake up every
morning wanting to protect their
billions your group one i'm grouped too
[Laughter]
that's great so
so in a way you have to be an optimist
to make two million you have to be your
best friend when you already made it
that's a great show it depends that's
probably why you become conservative
when you have that much money and you're
and you're a wild man when you're young
yeah that if when you get older you're
like
why like think about conservatives
conservatives are there to preserve what
we have and liberals are there to be
like let's let's let's start something
new bro progressives
you should be a money manager you'd be
one hell of a money man you'd crack up
your clients he said look you know what
i wasn't going to give you the other 20
million but here it is
you're going to make no money but i'll
make you laugh
too emotional so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]